c'est une bonne réforme sur les droits
des travailleurs
parce que c'est des avancées très
concrète très substantiel même et c'est
dans la transformation de la gouvernance
du système de formation une une alerte
que je fais au gouvernement attention à
pas des branches et des tuyaux et à
rebrancher d'autres ça va nous prendre
des années des années et ça risque de
rendre l'utilisation des droits mois
pertinente donc quoi vous vous
interrogiez est ce que vous êtes en
colère en colère je suis préoccupé je
suis à la fois satisfait qu'il ya des
droits des travailleurs plus pertinents
plus plus conséquent sur la formation
professionnelle et je suis préoccupé que
ces transformations que le la ministre
afin sans nous en avoir tellement alerté
en un mot puisque elle peut pas dire que
les partenaires sociaux n'ont pas voulu
faire cette réforme sur la gouvernance
elle nous a pas tellement sollicité dans
la lettre de cadrage le sujet eh bien je
suis préoccupé parce qu'il faut pas on
fera pas sur les branches
professionnelles
on fera pas sans les partenaires sociaux
on fera pas sur les organisations
syndicales sur les dans les territoires
pour savoir où sont les compagnies ou
sur les besoins de compétences et
comment ils répondent donc il faudra
travailler ensemble et à me retenir
sociaux c'est inventer un nouveau mode
de gouvernance
voilà moi je demande à rencontrer très
vite la ministre du travail pour qu'on
se mette d'accord sur comment ça va
fonctionner